- [Both] Thank you so much for watching.
(gasps)
- No.
- Dude.
- Did we just become best friends.
[Both] Again?
(beep)
- Hi, I'm Darren Barnett.
- And I'm Benjamin Norris.
We are about to prove
that we are best friends.
(quietly laughing)
- How close of a friend is Darren?
Well he's about two inches
away from me right now.
But sentimentally, I
literally love Darren Barnett.
- Way closer than two inches.
(hands clapping)
Don't ask about it.
Do I think Ben is gonna
get this one right?
No, I don't like that
face, so probably not.
I didn't even wanna look.
It's gonna really hurt
my feelings, isn't it?
What did you write?
- I said Paul or Anthony.
- Okay.
- That was my third guess.
- No, it wasn't.
- Yeah.
- Such a liar.
- It's my dad's name.
- Is your middle name?
- Should have known that.
- Is your middle name Alan?
- No.
(laughing)
- Dang it.
- He looks like Shakespeare.
- I covered all the bases here.
(laughing)
- Pretty much got it.
- Right.
- And I do love the crust
and the cheese.
- Yeah.
This is a trap of a question.
- Yeah, this is a.
- Cause if you get it right.
- Then someone's gonna get mad.
- If you get it right. I can't even
write anything down.
(laughing)
- Can already tell what's
happening, and I like it.
- Did we do it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. All right.
Yeah, yeah.
- So no one gets left out.
- Yeah.
♪ What's your Zodiac sign? ♪
- Stop singing.
I have this feeling, man,
that you're like an Aries or a Taurus.
Dang it.
Did I not get it?
Yeah.
I don't even know how to say that word.
- Oh, Darren didn't know
what a Sagittarius was.
- No.
- So that's why
he got it wrong.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Not much thinking.
- Yeah, not much to this one.
I'm writing this very
large and with a purpose.
- Lots of talks on set.
- Reveal time?
- Yeah, you know.
- I love you.
- You're just better than me.
- I'm. At one thing.
(laughing)
- I've just confided in
this man a lot, you know?
And he's sat and listened with his
perfect life and his perfect girlfriend.
- Not a.
- Fiance.
- About to be wife.
- About to be my wife.
- Actually, when this comes out,
she'll probably just be your wife.
- She'll be my wife.
- So your wife?
- My wife.
- Oh, man. I could just.
- This is easy.
- I could hear
what you were writing
and I already know your answer.
- What?
- Bro.
- No.
I heard the E.
- You were like, you were so like.
(pen tapping)
With the lines in it.
- You might have a better voice, but I,
I have a better stage presence.
- I know what you're thinking,
and I know what you're gonna do.
But it didn't go well, so don't do it.
- I actually shouldn't do it?
- I mean, yeah, don't do it.
- No. Right?
- Don't do it.
- Okay, okay.
- Okay.
(laughing)
Oh man, I meant to.
- That was good.
- Just so you know, Emily,
he has a huge heart.
I truly, I love him so much.
And he's a great person.
- Thanks, man.
- And he's not in high school.
- All right.
Let's see if you can understand that.
Just from that, those two words.
- I hate it.
- Yeah.
- People give fricks.
- Don't do it.
- We don't give fricks about anything.
- Anything.
- Except for each other.
- Yeah.
- And honestly, not even.
- And if it's past that, frick it.
- Frick it.
- You see, I told you we
were best friends for life.
Never Have I Ever Season 4,
is out June 8th, only on Netflix.
(lively music)
- Oh.
(laughing)
Dude, that's.
Warms my heart.
(outro music)